Hola Muy Bienvenidos a la entrevista de
Franz 24 en español nos acompaña en esta
oportunidad Ivana Aguilera ella es
sobreviviente trans de la última
dictadura Cívico militar Argentina un
país donde es toda una referente a nivel
nacional del activismo lgbtiq más es
directora del área trans travestis y no
binaries de la facultad de filosofía y
humanidades de la Universidad Nacional
de Córdoba en Argentina también es
fundadora de acodo la asociación contra
la discriminación homosexual y fundadora
además de la asociación civil flores
diversas y van a agregar a Muchísimas
gracias por su presencia en France 24 en
español
Bueno buenas tardes Muchas gracias por
la invitación gracias a usted una vez
más y van a se acaba de cumplir otro
aniversario de la última dictadura
Cívico militar en Argentina son
muchísimas las personas que al día de
hoy siguen denunciando que los crímenes
contra personas
lgbtiq más no han sido visibilizados y
tampoco por supuesto castigados que hay
detrás y van a de ese silenciamiento Por
qué cree que ocurre esto Bueno sí
obviamente que la población lgtbiq más
venimos denunciando No es cierto que hay
una invisibilización hacia nuestra
persecuciones
sobre todo la población trans y travesti
bueno Esto es producto no es de ahora
viene de cuando se conformó la conaded y
demás con las primeras 400 denuncias
dentro de las primeras Diez mil
cuatrocientos se referían a personas
trans
homosexuales o lesbianas No es cierto
pero bueno por un acuerdo del ala
católica que estaban en los grupos de la
conadet se decidió que de estas cosas no
se hablaban no solamente de identidades
textuales sino también de violaciones
sexuales Bueno es un poco es
la iglesia la que tapa toda esta
persecución No es cierto el sistema de
Dictadura que vino a reformar y a poner
orden en el país también lo vino a poner
a nivel sexual y de género No es cierto
claro y sus cuerpos dientes claramente
molestaban no a los militares que
estaban en el poder ahora Ivana en esta
tarea tan necesaria de visibilización no
que es clave es necesario que sus
propias voces sean escuchadas no que no
hablen por ustedes otras voces sus
historias de vida sus experiencias son
parte muy necesarias de la lucha por la
justicia la memoria y la verdad usted
tenía tan solo 13 años cuando los
militares tomaron el poder aquel 24 de
marzo de 1976 y una tarde de mayo de ese
mismo año en la ciudad de Rosario en
Argentina tuviste tu primer cara a cara
con esa violencia inhumana genocida de
la dictadura de la crueldad que ejercían
específicamente contra las personas
trans cuéntenos Qué ocurrió y que vino a
partir de ese momento
Bueno lo que pasó que como siendo una
niña y en plena construcción de mi
identidad este fui absorbida este por el
ejército llevada
mi Debut sexual Por así decirlo fue una
violación grupal
acompañada de torturas golpes
corriente eléctrica no cierto picana e
insultos hacia mi identidad y hacia mi
expresión de género
que vino a partir de ahí solamente vino
el horror y el preguntarme el Por qué se
este Después fui entendiendo que el
poner el orden que esta gente venía no
solamente era el orden vuelvo a ser
reiterativa de reestructuración nacional
también venían por por la identidad de
género Bueno pasó eso que siendo muy
niña fui fui encarcelado torturada
violentada sexualmente
y Esto fue continuo porque la población
Transit travesti durante dictadura si
toda la población
carecía de derechos nosotras carecíamos
absolutamente De nada ni siquiera hemos
teníamos derecho a una vía Corpus como
tenían los demás éramos carnes de cañón
porque los militares nos llevaban donde
nos visualizaban y nos nos vendían como
pedazos de carne éramos utilizadas para
su satisfacción sexual y nosotros
venimos del colectivo denunciando esto y
poniendo en evidencia esto porque
necesitamos que nuestras historias sean
escuchadas necesitamos que nuestros
violadores nuestros cactores nuestros
torturadores nuestros asesinos sean
enjuiciados queremos estar sentadas
sentados sentados frente a ellos y
Queremos escuchar una sentencia donde se
le explique y se les diga que ellos son
violadores
hay que dejar bien en claro estos
señores no solamente eran asesinos
torturadores y eran pedófilos eran
pedófilos porque yo era una criatura
tenía 12 años a punto de cumplir 13
y y yo quiero que se sepa que estos
señores también eran pedófilos y
necesitamos urgentemente empezar a
trabajar nosotros venimos trabajando
desde hace unos años en la
reconstrucción de la memoria lgtbiq más
durante la dictadura Y tenemos hace muy
pocos años un trabajo que hemos empezado
muy importante sobre las identidades
trans y travesti que fuimos perseguidas
en dictadura nosotras en la ciudad de
Rosario éramos 56 compañeras y quedamos
solamente once a través de esas once
compañeras hicimos un registro histórico
con el cual se conformó el archivo
historias transi y de Dictadura en en
Rosario No es cierto y es un trabajo que
nosotros venimos haciendo y le pedimos
totalmente la justicia Federal porque la
justicia Federal la que lleva estos
casos adelante Que bueno que tome cartas
en el asunto y sea rápido en poder tener
juicio porque nosotros somos adultos
mayores nuestros cactores nuestro
violadores esos pedófilos que nos
secuestraron también son adultos y se
van a morir sin el castigo
correspondiente
mucho de ustedes habían sido expulsadas
incluso de sus hogares bueno mucha parte
de la población
lgbtiq más específicamente
Lamentablemente la población trans
muchísimas veces es expulsada de sus
hogares no sufren la exclusión desde el
seno de su familia o sea no había
personas que lo reclamaran como Sí
ocurría con muchísimas personas que
estaban desaparecidas no en cierto
aspecto cree Quizás es polémica la frase
Pero bueno sirve como disparador para
analizar no
cree que quizás la memoria en alguna
manera es un privilegio heterosexual
sí venimos luchando contra eso no es
cierto
si bien nosotros entendemos y llevamos
adelante la bandera de 30.000 compañeros
desaparecidos Nosotros le hemos agregado
un número que es el número cuatrocientos
que son el testimonio de cuatrocientos
compañeros
tortas trans travesti que fueron
asesinados y que fueron reclamados ellos
por su familia pero estamos hablando de
una población que generalmente no
tenemos el acompañamiento familiar qué
pasa con aquellos y esos cuatrocientos
que fueron reclamados por sus familiares
no son nombrados no se los visualiza no
se investiga Qué pasó con ellos
imaginemos todo esa población que no
nadie lo ha podido reclamar no se supone
que son los Derechos Humanos que tienen
que acompañar para que se sepa qué pasó
con ellos también Entonces nosotros
entendemos que es de nosotros que
tenemos que tomar la posta y empezar a
trabajar para recuperar
podría no cierto del colectivo lgtbiq
más de la población Transit travesti que
fue perseguida durante dictadura y que
sigue y seguimos sufriendo una
persecución continua el genocidio hace
la población a través y trans en el
mundo pero sobre todo en Argentina hablo
de mi país es la expectativa de vida de
una persona trans es De 35 a 40 años
y aquellas personas que hemos
sobrepasado esa expectativa de vida nos
encontramos con adultezas convejece
sumamente precarias entonces en los
estados hay una conexión muy directa
entre la persecución y el genocidio que
sufríamos durante la dictadura militar Y
en la persecución No es cierto y este
genocidio constante hacia la población
Transit travesti aún hoy en democracia
porque no hay otra población que tenga
una expectativa de vida de 35 a 40 años
no hay otra población que todavía no
podamos tener derecho a tener vivienda
tener educación a tener un trabajo a
poder tener justicia
y van a como ustedes bien decía la
violencia hacia las travestis todo el
colectivo lgbti no finalizaron con la
dictadura de hecho tampoco comenzaron
con la dictadura la democracia no puso
final a esa violencia usted sobrevivió a
la Dictadura y también a la democracia
podríamos decir de alguna manera
y totalmente la persecución en Argentina
hacia la hacia la población lgtbiq más
le tenemos registro que empezó en el año
y de ahí en adelante y hemos pasado por
diferentes dictaduras y siempre la
población lgtbq más ha sido este
perseguidas durante las dictaduras y
Durante los gobiernos democráticos
porque han sostenido
aquellos edictos que fueron creados en
dictadura No es cierto Y sí yo sobre
dictadura y soy una sobreviviente del
sistema democrático en mi país a 40 años
de haber logrado la democracia somos una
población Que vuelvo a decirte tenemos
la expectativa de vida de 35 a 40 años
y van a para ir cerrando Ya esta
entrevista qué podemos esperar está en
sus manos verdad en las manos de lo que
es el activismo no la búsqueda de
justicia de memoria y de verdad para
estas al menos cuatrocientas Víctimas de
la población
lgbtiq más de la última dictadura Cívico
militar Argentina
Sí por supuesto está en manos nuestra y
nosotros venimos con otro compañero que
hoy nos encuentra
Juan vida compañero Eugenio talbohui un
compañero atrás también sobrevivió en su
momento sobrevivente de Dictadura
venimos haciendo un trabajo para que
nuestra comunidad tome banquera
explicando esta problemática y los
últimos años en la marcha de 24 de marzo
cada vez son más los carteles y las
pagan cartas que aparecen
en la marcha
reclamando por los treinta mil
cuatrocientos Entonces eso a mí me pone
contenta Cuál es el trabajito bueno
trabajar por estos cuatrocientos
compañeros para poder darle
visibilización poder empezar a construir
su historia Y desde ahí empezará a
buscar aquellos compañeros No es cierto
que que nadie reclamó pero que sabemos
que están en algún y menester nuestro No
es cierto empezar con ese trabajo y Y
desde ahí convidar al Estado para que
empiece también a preocuparse por
nosotras venimos haciendo un trabajo
también con la justicia federal y demás
nos cuesta muchísimo pero es un trabajo
que venimos haciendo hace muchos años y
bueno la semillita y como toda semilla
hay que de regarla cuidarla y continuar
exactamente
Muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
France 24 gracias por su testimonio Y
por supuesto que sea justicia
por supuesto Muchísimas gracias a
ustedes por poder ponerme dejarme poner
la voz y 30.400 compañeros presentes hoy
y siempre Muchísimas gracias Muchísimas
gracias a nuestra audiencia le invitamos
a que sigan informándose en el resto de
nuestra programación también en France
24 punto com en todas nuestras redes
sociales y no olviden que la entrevista
también está disponible para ser
escuchada en Spotify sigan junto a
nosotros